[Music]
we've been under siege for six days now
uncle deckard is still missing captain
rumford and the others are losing hope
i tell them not to lose faith but if
help doesn't arrive
soon
sixteen militiamen went out only rumford
came back
how could that help us we never should
have built on this cursed ground
zakarum has fallen to disgrace
how can i help fight the risen dead i
admire your courage but
captain dalton and the militia were
slaughtered by those things
only i survived you're warriors well i
have seen you fight
strike at the wretched they're attacking
the barricades
that's one of the wretched mothers down
the road
hey
i decade
uh
so
the ancients have blessed me
uh
so
so
while exploring a cave with hopes of
finding hidden treasure
i came upon a most grisly sight a heap
of dead bodies
unbelievably as i was searching them for
any items of value
they began to rise i must tell them of
this in nutristrum before it's too late
task is these unholy creatures can rest
[Music]
i now enjoy this
i gain new strength
oh
old tristram diablo himself once walked
this place
[Music]
thank you for your help but could you
talk some sense into leah she won't give
up nor should she
i promised marco i'd protect him but now
he's dead
you